[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances mes chers
collègues
j'ai l'honneur au nom des députés
socialistes de demander à l'Assemblée
nationale la nationalisation du groupe
Électricité de France
cette phrase
prononcer ici à la tribune peut sembler
extraordinaire
durant les 25 dernières années 7
assemblée n'a cessé d'adopter des textes
ayant méthodiquement détruit et
démantelé ce qui faisait notre fierté
nationale
un service public unifié de l'énergie
qui procurerait à la France
l'électricité la moins chère d'Europe et
aux Français la fierté d'un service
fiable basé sur une industrie nucléaire
garantissant à chacun des Français un
approvisionnement en électricité
cette oeuvre de destruction a pris
plusieurs étapes la première avec la
mise en concurrence et l'entrée de la
France dans le marché européen de
l'électricité ensuite l'ouverture du
capital d'électricité de France
suivi par l'ouverture du capital de Gaz
de France avec la fusion avec Suez
suivi par la terrible loi Nome qui a
imposé à EDF notre opérateur national de
devoir vendre en dessous de ses coups
d'électricité à des fournisseurs
alternatifs qui n'ont de fournisseurs
que le nom et qui n'ont jamais respecté
les obligations de production qui leur
avait été fixées
cette oeuvre de destruction a
aujourd'hui des conséquences directes
directes sur nos commerçants et nos
artisans direct aussi sur notre
population avec l'explosion des prix de
l'électricité qui aujourd'hui mettent à
contribution notre nos finances
publiques à hauteur de 100 milliards
d'euros sur les deux dernières années
avec le bouclier tarifaire 100 milliards
d'euros c'est justement ce que doit
coûter le nouveau programme nucléaire
annoncé par le président de la
République cette inacceptable mettant
danger nos collectivités mettant danger
nos entreprises et nous voyons tous dans
nos circonscriptions la détresse de nos
artisans la détresse de nos boulangers
la détresse de ces femmes et de ses
hommes qui après la mise à jour de leur
tarifs d'électricité de leur contrat
doivent aujourd'hui faire face au dépôt
de bilan
un chiffre simple que je prends que je
tire de ma collègue Valérie rabot la
marge brute consolidée de l'ensemble des
boulangeries françaises et de 1,5
milliards d'euros l'augmentation des
prix de l'électricité coûtera au
boulangerie française en 2023 1,6
milliards d'euros là il a conséquence de
cette œuvre de destruction et nous
devons aujourd'hui trouver mes chers
collègues les moyens de la
reconstruction de notre service public
de l'énergie alors cette proposition de
loi qui n'est pas parfaite vise pour la
première fois depuis 25 ans à revenir
sur cette dérive libérale
à l'article premier de cette proposition
de loi nous affirmons la nationalisation
du groupe Électricité de France cette
nationalisation n'a rien à voir avec
l'OPA décidé par le gouvernement une
opération de sortie de côte dont nous
avons tous compris qu'elle n'était que
le préalable à une réorganisation du
groupe et à la vente en particulier ces
activités liées à la transition
énergétique telle que j'ai pu le révéler
à la suite du contrôle sur pièce et sur
place que j'ai effectué au ministère de
l'économie et des finances
l'article 2 de cette proposition de loi
tire les conséquences de la
nationalisation en définissant chacune
des activités du Groupe EDF ainsi le
gouvernement ne pourra procéder au
démantèlement et au démembrement de
notre
énergéticien national chacune de ces
activités sera définie et les projets
dont nous entendons parler aujourd'hui
de vente rapide de Dalkia ou de vente
rapide d'EDF énergie renouvelable seront
ainsi impossibles et si le gouvernement
souhaite le faire il devra alors saisir
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat et de
déposer un projet de loi modifiant le
nouvel article de le code de l'énergie
que nous ajoutons avec cet article 2
l'article 3 de ce projet de loi tire
également la conséquence des nombreux
recours aujourd'hui dirigés contre cette
opération vous le savez le prix
notamment de cette opération de monter
au capital ne fait pas consensus il y a
aujourd'hui de nombreux actionnaires qui
s'estiment laissés après avoir acheté
pour certains je pense notamment aux
actionnaires salariés d'EDF leurs
actions à plus de 60 euros l'action et
qui doivent aujourd'hui la vendre forcée
à hauteur de 12 euros des recours sont
en cours devant le Conseil d'État devant
également la cour d'appel de Paris et
nous devons sécuriser l'opération
si ces recours valide l'opération alors
la nationalisation aura lieu dans les
conditions fixées par la présente loi si
les recours sont acceptés et que l'OPA
mis en place par le gouvernement est
annulé alors nous prévoyons un mécanisme
de nationalisation sur le fondement de
l'article 34 de la Constitution une
commission sera constituée présidée par
le Premier Président de la Cour des
comptes pour fixer le prix de la
nationalisation cette commission nous en
avons repris les termes de celles qui
avaient été créées déjà en 1982 lors des
grandes lois de nationalisation
et puis nous avons décidé lors de la
commission des finances de mercredi
dernier de tirer toute la conséquence de
la crise que nous vivons aujourd'hui sur
nos territoires j'ai pour ma part dans
ma circonscription une dizaine de
boulangeries qui menacent de fermeture
j'ai une quarantaine d'industriels qui
sont venus me voir pour me dire pitié
monsieur le député rétablissez les
tarifs réglementés de l'électricité et
nationaliser EDF
notre compétitivité
et gravement mis à mal pensez qu'il y a
20 ans l'électricité était en France 40%
moins cher qu'en Allemagne alors qu'elle
est aujourd'hui 5% plus cher qu'en
France et vous pouvez faire mes chers
collègues toutes les réformes fiscales
du monde toutes les baisses de
cotisation sociale du monde toutes les
réformes du Code du travail du monde
rien n'est Gallera cette augmentation
endémique des prix de l'électricité qui
est un risque majeur pour la
compétitivité de notre pays pour son
commerce extérieur pour sa production et
en cela nous devons lutter pour rétablir
justement les tarifs réglementés de
l'électricité
alors nous commençons le chemin avec cet
article 3 bises que nous avons adopté en
commission des finances quel est le
principe et bien d'appliquer les tarifs
réglementés un nouveau tarif réglementé
de vente d'électricité qui
s'appliquerait à toutes les entreprises
de moins de 5000 salariés et de 2
milliards de chiffres d'affaires ainsi
nous protégerons nos artisans nos
commerçants nos industriels nos
entreprises de taille intermédiaires
contre la spéculation du marché européen
de l'énergie qui ne sert aucun autre
intérêt que celui des spéculateurs et
aucun autre bénéfice que celui
de la finance des opérateurs alternatifs
et en particulier de Total énergie qui a
récemment affiché des super profits dont
personne absolument personne ne peut
trouver d'autres explications que cette
spéculation indigne
voilà mes chers collègues l'économie du
texte qui vous est présenté un texte qui
ne règle pas tous les problèmes du
marché de l'énergie et à ceux qui et
j'en fais partie voudraient que la
France suspente sa participation
provisoirement au marché européen de
l'énergie nous ne pouvons
malheureusement pas sortir du marché
européen de l'énergie par amendement
toutefois ce texte vient mettre
un grain de sable dans la mécanique bien
huilé de libéralisation et de
destruction du service public mes chers
collègues la semaine dernière en
commission des finances pour la première
fois depuis 25 ans une majorité de
députés à l'Assemblée nationale votait
pour le retour du service public et
contre l'allergie la dérégulation du
marché européen de l'énergie
aujourd'hui mes chers collègues
j'appelle à l'ensemble de députés de
continuer sur ce chemin afin d'offrir à
la France un service public de l'énergie
qui n'aurait jamais dû la quitter et en
faisant cela les députés non seulement
viseront l'intérêt national
intérêt national et l'intérêt public
mais qui est aussi l'intérêt de
l'humanité tout entière tant
l'électricité comme l'eau et l'air est
un bien public qui ne veut faire l'objet
d'aucune concurrence qui peut faire
l'objet d'aucun marchandage et qui doit
à tout prix aujourd'hui être retiré du
marché alors mes chers collègues il faut
que cette journée du 9 février fasse
date dans l'histoire et que le 9 février
soit et j'en suis avec vous convaincu la
date du grand retour du service public
en France
je vous remercie
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le débat député Sébastien Jumel il y a
près de 80 ans un de vos illustres
prédécesseurs mais aussi un des miens
Monsieur Marcel Paul à l'époque ministre
de la Production industrielle
les députés communistes et résistants
créés Électricité de France
il crée par le même un monopole de
l'énergéticien qui a conduit je pense
que nous en sommes tous fiers sur ces
bancs
à l'électrification du pays et à la
construction du deuxième parc nucléaire
au monde
reconnaît sur le haut on envoie encore
les fruits aujourd'hui le mix électrique
français et parmi les moins émissives de
CO2 au monde et ça a été dit parmi les
plus compétitifs
ce mouvement a été vous le savez
interrompu il y a un peu plus de 20 ans
dans un monde assez différent de celui
qui prévalait en 1946 par une loi la loi
de février 2000 sur la modernisation du
service public de l'électricité et au
sommet de Barcelone en mars 2002 qui
formalisait l'acte de la libéralisation
du marché de l'électricité et du gaz
mesdames messieurs les députés à
l'époque le président de la République
c'était Jacques Chirac le Premier
ministre c'était Lionel Jospin et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon était membre du
gouvernement
c'est vrai qu'il y avait pas de
communiste gouvernement en revanche il y
avait un socialiste depuis devenu leader
Maximus de l'insoumission
ah non c'est vrai qu'en 2000 il était
pas ministre il était juste au sénateur
en revanche en 2002 je vous le rappelle
il était monsieur Corbière donc relisez
vos dates le ministre le gouvernement
qui a signé et adopté et accepter l'acte
qui libéralisait le marché européen de
l'électricité votre leader en était
membre et le Premier ministre monsieur
Brun vous aviez 10 ans à l'époque
c'était Lionel Jospin la parole est à
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie de
le laisser terminer je vous remercie
le marché européen de l'électricité il
est loin d'être parfait il est loin
d'être parfait et vous le savez le
gouvernement travaille d'arrache-pied
depuis plus d'un an
pour en modifier le fonctionnement et
quelques effets pervers vous le savez
évidemment
aujourd'hui la guerre en Ukraine l'a
montré de manière assez forte la
difficulté
à protéger les consommateurs de la
volatilité des marchés de l'électricité
est un des travailleurs du marché
européen auquel nous travaillons
soyons donc lucides faisons évoluer le
marché mais ne jetons pas le bébé avec
l'eau du bain n'oublions pas non plus
que le marché européen de l'électricité
monsieur Brun
c'est grâce à lui aujourd'hui que nous
avons de l'électricité dans cette pièce
aujourd'hui que vous le vouliez ou non
une partie de l'électricité qui éclaire
la France vient de centrale à gaz qui
nous proviennent d'Allemagne
grâce à la libéralisation monsieur le
rapporteur EDF est devenu un des grands
champions européens de l'électricité
grâce à la libéralisation évidemment
très utile quand EDF n'est pas au
rendez-vous de la production nous
pouvons importer de la production
d'ailleurs et enfin très important et là
c'est le député qui jusqu'à quelques
mois représentait les Français
d'Amérique du Nord qui a vu des blackout
en Californie
quand l'opérateur californien était
incapable de livrer et que la Californie
était incapable du fait de l'absence
d'une plaque de distribution
d'électricité d'importer de
l'électricité du Texas
en tout cas les États-Unis sont pas le
modèle d'un mode d'un marché intégré
d'électricité contrairement à l'Europe
qu'il l'est
votre proposition de loi monsieur le
rapporteur elle est en de nombreux
points et j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir
en contradiction avec le droit européen
et je ne suis pas surpris face à ses
arguments d'entendre des cris d'or frais
de l'extrême droite je suis un peu plus
surpris monsieur le rapporteur qu'une
proposition de loi qui controvient en
temps de points
à la loi européenne puis c'est Mané d'un
groupe socialiste notamment allant à
l'encontre je le répète puisque vous ne
m'écoutiez pas tout à l'heure quand je
l'ai dit d'une directive adoptée par un
gouvernement Jospin
notre vision mesdames et messieurs les
députés du groupe EDF quel est-elle
d'abord ça a été dit et répété par le
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique ici à l'Assemblée ça a été
écrit par la première ministre dans la
lettre de mission au nouveau PDG d'EDF
le groupe EDF est et restera un
instrument essentiel pour mettre en
oeuvre la politique énergétique de
l'État français et au-delà sa politique
industrielle j'y suis extrêmement
sensible et c'est important également un
champion à l'exportation
je suis vraiment content d'être venu
monsieur Tanguy pour entendre ce genre
de choses aujourd'hui la France fait
face à un déficit commercial extrêmement
important comment allons-t-on le
réserver
en fermant les portes en fermant les
frontières en empêchant nos entreprises
industrielles françaises de se
développer à l'industriel bien au
contraire évidemment
aujourd'hui la filière nucléaire
française c'est plus de 200000 salariés
c'est plus de 3000 entreprises de taille
petite moyenne et intermédiaire qui
contribue au rayonnement de la filière
export française qui contribue au
rayonnement d'électricité de France avec
votre proposition de loi vous faites
porter un risque juridique extrêmement
important sur la capacité d'EDF à se
développer et notamment à
l'international
EDF qu'est-ce que c'est aujourd'hui
quelle doit être a priorité de cette
grande entreprise c'est des dizaines de
milliards d'euros d'investissements tous
les ans pour lesquels il faut des moyens
et de la crédibilité financière c'est
retrouver sa maîtrise industrielle dans
le nucléaire c'est une stratégie j'y
reviendrai dans une minute c'est monter
sur les énergies renouvelables chers au
mouvement écologistes et au groupe qui
les représentent ici avec des objectifs
ambitieux pour les 30 prochaines années
et pour cela le gouvernement a pris ses
responsabilités l'État a toujours
accompagné EDF dans ces opérations de
rock capitalisation ça a été le cas en
2017 ça a été le cas en 2022 on n'a
jamais autant investi dans le nucléaire
que depuis 2017 et vous le savez nous
allons continuer à le faire vérifier les
chiffres je les ai à votre disposition
nous sécurisons le calendrier de le père
de avec un projet de loi nucléaire que
je vous engage à voter à l'instar de vos
collègues sénateurs
maintenant reconnaissons la réalité de
la situation d'EDF également EDF est une
société endettée avec de gros besoins
d'investissement donc conformément aux
engagements du Président de la
République nous avons lancé cet été une
offre publique d'achat pour prendre le
contrôle à 100% du capital d'odève si
c'est pas une nationalisation ça y
ressemble furieusement nous avons voté
et vous auriez pu monsieur le rapporteur
avoir l'honneur de les voter vous vous
êtes refusé
9,7 milliards il voulait l'honneur de
nationaliser EDF vous avez six mois de
retard vous vous êtes abstenus avec
votre groupe sur de projets de loi pour
voir d'achat qui visait 9,7 milliards de
crédit budgétaires qui ont été validés
par cette majorité
avec cette nationalisation qui est
presque complète j'y viens dans une
seconde nous renforçons les moyens d'EDF
pour investir dans les prochaines années
et nous crédibilisons son sérieux
financé vous l'avez compris ce
gouvernement répond pleinement au vrai
problème du groupe def
face à ça que nous proposez-vous
monsieur le rapporteur une proposition
de loi juridiquement bancale au minimum
inutile mais sans doute pire
contre-productive parce qu'elle va à
rebours des objectifs que nous portons
pour l'avenir d'EDF
le gouvernement étant désaccord complet
avec ce texte et demande à la
représentation nationale de le rejeter
et plus en détail je vous donnerai mon
avis rapide sur tous les articles qui
permettra d'avoir des prises de parole
plus courtes dans le cadre de la
discussion des amendements d'abord les
articles 1 et 3 vous l'avez dit sur le
rapporteur qui introduisent une
nationalisation d'EDF par la loi je le
rappelle il existe une opération de
marché elle est en cours qui remplit
exactement le même objectif et cette
opération est un franc succès ce qui
montre bien l'inutilité de cette
proposition de loi au pire je le répète
sa contre-productivité puisque vous
risquez de mettre éventuellement un
risque l'opération en cours
vous l'avez compris d'ailleurs puisque
vous avez changé le nom de vos
propositions loi en cours de route
passant de la nationalisation d'EDF à la
protection d'EDF face à un démembrement
évidemment totalement hypothétique que
vous seul voyez une proposition de loi
qui arrive je le répète au mieux à
contretemps puisque vous le savez
monsieur le rapporteur d'ici juin 2023
l'état détiendra 100% du capital d'EDF
nous l'avons rendu public hier à la
clôture de l'opé à vendredi près de 96%
du capital et déjà acquis
soit plus que le seuil de 80 % qui nous
permet de procéder au retrait
obligatoire des minoritaires restants
nous pourrions d'ailleurs le faire dès
aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit un recours
est en cours de la part d'un certain
nombre d'actionnaires minoritaires et
nous nous sommes donc engagés à attendre
la décision de la cour d'appel qui
arrivera au plus tard début mai sur ce
recours porté par des actionnaires
minoritaires et donc d'ici le mois de
juin cette entreprise sera nationale
elle sera détenue à 100% par l'État et
votre proposition de loi aura vécu je
pense par son inutilité
l'article 2 souhaite la création d'un
groupe unifié le gouvernement a déjà dit
que le démembrement le démantèlement des
mots que j'ai entendu dans votre bouche
monsieur le rapporteur ne sont en aucun
cas notre projet et nous avons confirmé
renoncé au projet Hercule le ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté numérique industrielle
Bruno la maire vous l'a dit dans cette
salle dès le mois de juillet 2022 il la
redit le 9 décembre dernier à Penly la
première ministre l'a écrit et
puisqu'elle affûté je peux vous
confirmer que dans la lettre mission de
la première ministre au PDG d'EDF
sont explicitement mentionnés que le
projet Hercule ayant été abandonné par
le gouvernement je souhaite que vous
puissiez proposer en lien avec toutes
les parties prenantes de l'entreprise
une feuille de route stratégique parce
que j'ai un scoop pour vous Mesdames et
Messieurs le député
le président directeur général d'EDF
dont vous avez validé la candidature
peut-être pas chacun d'entre vous mais
vous tous
et bien ce n'est pas Philippe Brun ce
n'est pas Roland Lescure c'est du
crémant et c'est donc lui dans le cadre
d'une gouvernance saine et normale d'une
entreprise publique ou non qui va
proposer un projet stratégique que vous
aurez tout loisir
d'auditionner d'écouter de challenger
quand il sera disponible
en attendant votre proposition de loi Me
sur le rapporteur elle fait porter des
risques réels à l'écosystème énergétique
dont j'ai présenté je pense toutes les
vertus il y a quelques minutes
si vous avez monsieur le rapporteur si
vous aviez auditionnaire RTE vous saurez
carte est extrêmement inquiet et ils
auront sans doute l'occasion de vous le
dire s'il vous les additionnez à
l'avenir parce que là encore évidemment
je comprends que certains ici
s'engouce mais qu'un représentant du
parti socialiste une fois de plus
présente un article qui est une
contravention à l'ensemble des
directives européennes qui sur le marché
tailleur de l'électricité je les cite
rapidement celle du 19 décembre 1996 qui
met en place la séparation comptable
celle du vin juin 2023 qui met en place
la séparation juridique celle du 13
juillet 2009 qui met en place la
séparation effective monsieur le
rapporteur les héritiers de Mitterrand
et de Jospin méritaient mieux je suis
désolé que vous ayez décidé d'aller en
contravention flagrante avec les
directives européennes
pourquoi pourquoi RTE et pourquoi son
indépendance est-elle si importante
parce que ça ne vous a pas échappé il y
a aujourd'hui d'autres producteurs
d'énergie en France et vu les besoins
massifs d'électricité dont nous allons
avoir besoin vu les besoins massifs
d'énergie renouvelables dont nous allons
avoir besoin dans les années qui
viennent il me semble opportun que oui
total énergie puisse se développer que
oui engie puisse se développer et que
oui évidemment EDF puisse se développer
de manière extrêmement ambitieuse avec
un réseau d'électricité indépendant qui
gère ces trois compétiteurs de manière
juste parfaite et qui en passant et là
j'en appelle au groupe écologiste qui
fait souvent référence au scénario RTE
et notamment un scénario qui si je ne
m'abuse je suis pas sûr d'y croire
totalement mais RTE je le répète est
indépendant qu'on peut se passer
complètement du nucléaire dans les
décédés qui viennent et qu'un scénario
100% renouvelable existe vous pensez
vraiment que si RTE était une filiale à
100% de DF ce scénario serait disponible
aujourd'hui personnellement j'en doute
ce texte imprécie qui conduirait à de
l'impossibilité de faire des activités
commerciales à l'étranger mesdames et
messieurs couperaient les ailes de notre
champion national si vous pensez si vous
pensez
que votre projet de loi permet à EDF de
continuer à conquérir l'Europe affaire
fructifier une filière qui crée de
l'emploi en France à s'assurer que les
talents qui aujourd'hui vont construire
les opère vont être toujours présents en
France vous vous trompez messieurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés les
deux dernières années est-ce qu'on a des
membré EDF
non ces deux dernières années EDF est
resté intègre entier et unis et pour
autant et pour autant monsieur le
rapporteur le groupe a acheté est vendu
sur cette période des parts des
activités de ces filiales comme le font
tous les grands groupes industriels qui
se développent et s'adaptent aux
évolutions en France le Groupe EDF a
cédé Dalkia West énergie une filiale de
gestion des déchets est-ce que DF à
vocation à gérer des déchets en France
non cette filiale elle a été vendue à
Paprec un groupe français qui lui se
développe dans cette filière extrêmement
porteuse malheureusement la proposition
là que vous proposez si elle avait un
adopté aurait fait peser un risque
juridique important à cette opération
capitalistique gagnante pour EDF
gagnante pour Paprec
à l'international le Groupe EDF ACD aux
États-Unis près de 50% d'une signale que
détenait qui n'était plus en phase avec
les orientations stratégiques du groupe
est-ce que quand EDF décide de vendre un
trader d'énergie aux États-Unis qui n'a
sans doute pas vocation on s'en moque
est-ce qu'il doit du coup venir ici à
genoux vous demander l'autorisation
parce que vous avez voté une loi qui a
attendu un risque juridique autour de
cette introduction nous aurons occasion
dans débattre
enfin monsieur le président de la
commission des finances
l'article 3 bis dont je dois avouer
qu'en tant qu' ancien président de
commission j'ai été déçu mais c'est
votre prérogative qu'il a été jugé
recevable il est en vue
lien avec le texte pour le moins
distendu mais c'est votre rebeu
prérogative cet article 3 bis introduit
un tre pour les TPE PME et ETI qui
serait substitiables au contrat en cours
et la séparation des pouvoirs monsieur
jumelle je la respecte j'ai interrogé à
haute voix la recevabilité mais je me
permettrai évidemment pas d'en juger
d'Inn en décider ce que j'ai fait avec
bonheur pendant 5 ans
mais toujours est-il que sur le fond
cette mesure qui coûte 18 milliards
comment vous la financez en spoliant def
qui sera elle-même en charge de payer la
facture ou en spoliant les fournisseurs
d'électricité ou en augmentant une fois
de plus les impôts des Françaises et des
Français ces 18 milliards vous les
retrouvez où je n'en sais pas mais la
réalité en tout cas ce dont je suis sûr
c'est que cette mesure donnerait
aujourd'hui un avantage à des
entreprises qui n'en n'ont pas besoin je
connais des entreprises de taille
intermédiaires françaises extrêmement
compétitive qui aujourd'hui exporte plus
de 90% de leur production à l'étranger
qui ont augmenté leur prix du fait de la
hausse des coûts avec mode mesure vous
ne ferez qu'une chose subventionné les
consommateurs canadiens américains
indiens et italiens de cette entreprise
qui n'a pas besoin de vous merci pour
payer ses factures énergétiques donc
soyons raisonnables avec les données
publiques soyons économe
ton nom et c'est déjà pas mal d'un
certain nombre de mesures qui je le
répète ont été votés par cette majorité
qui font qu'aujourd'hui l'économie
française est protégée mieux qu'aucune
en Europe contre cette crise énergétique
qui fait que l'inflation européenne et
la plus faible d'Europe qui fait que la
croissance en France reste positive
grâce à vous et grâce à nous bref
restons raisonnable
vous l'avez compris la position du
gouvernement
vous demande de rejeter en bloc ce texte
qui ne renforce en aucun cas la
souveraineté énergétique de la France ne
protège en aucun cas EDF mais
n'empêchera de se développer en tant que
ministre de l'Industrie j'ai besoin d'un
opérateur industriel énergétique fort
les industriels français qui
s'installent en France celles et ceux
qui décarbonne leur industrie ont besoin
d'un opérateur industriel fort ils ont
besoin d'un opérateur industriel qui
dans les années qui viennent va se
contenter va se concentrer sur trois
choses
la gestion de son bilan de manière à
s'assurer que cette entreprise retrouve
une santé financière durable le
développement des capacités de
production à long terme qui vont faire
que l'industrie française va continuer à
bénéficier d'une électricité des
carbonée et pas cher et c'est la moindre
des choses une capacité à livrer de
manière opérationnelle les électrons qui
nous éclairent aujourd'hui
face à ça vous proposez une loi je le
répète qui est au pire inutile sans
doute inopérante qui va si jamais elle
était adoptée ce que je n'espère pas
évidemment focaliser le management d'EDF
sur des enjeux de gouvernance de capital
de gestion d'opérations qui n'ont rien à
voir avec les priorités que nous
devrions tous affecter aujourd'hui à
notre opérateur national toutes ces
raisons font et expliquent je l'espère
les raisons pour laquelle nous sommes
opposés à cette proposition de loi nous
sommes évidemment ouverts au dialogue et
attendons avec impatience celui qui
commence merci
je vous remercie rappelle au règlement
allez-y
merci madame la Présidente c'est un
rappel au règlement au titre de
l'article 89 4 de notre règlement ce qui
se passe avec cette PPL est très grave
et je voudrais l'expliquer très
rapidement il ne fait absolument aucun
doute que l'article 40 de la
Constitution doit être opposée à la
partie l'article 3 bis de cette PPL qui
est issu d'un amendement du rapporteur
lui-même complété par des sous
amendements d'un certain nombre de notre
collègue cet article étant le bénéfice
de la de la trve à toutes et donc le
bouclier tarifaire à toutes les PME
jusqu'à 5000 salariés je ne suis pas là
pour juger de l'intérêt ou pas du fond
de cet article juste dire que il le crée
de toute évidence une charge publique et
d'évasion massive pour les finances de
l'État
même le rapporteur même le rapporteur
l'a dit je me permets de le citer dans
les dans l'exposé sommaire de son
amendement il parle des contraintes
portant sur la recevabilité financière
de l'initiative parlementaire dans
l'examen de son amendement il parle de
du coup important pour les finances
publiques dans son rapport d'écrit de
l'article 3 bis il part du dispositif du
bouclier tarifaire et de son extension
monsieur Bouloux d'ailleurs parlait
aussi de cette extension même le
président de la commission
des finances précises
déclaré irrecevable au titre de
l'article 40 un certain nombre
d'amendements qui est étendait aussi le
TR le trve donc malgré cela malgré cela
le président Coquerel a déclaré ses
amendements recevables et contre la vie
ce matin du bureau de la commission des
finances il a refusé de retirer du texte
l'article 3 bis donc de ce texte je
pense que c'est un je pense que c'est un
précédent extrêmement grave pour nos
institutions c'est une violation très
claire de l'article 40 de notre
Constitution nous sommes là pour faire
la loi nous sommes aussi là pour
respecter la loi mes chers donc je
souhaiterais que la Commission
que le bureau de la commission des
finances soit de nouveau réunis pour
statuer sur cette formation on va donner
la parole à Monsieur Coquerel
merci
je souhaiterais pondre
au rapporteur comme j'ai d'ailleurs
répondu par écrit avant
cette séance aux membres du bureau j'ai
donc été conduit examiné en effet en
application du quatrième alinéa de
l'article 89 du règlement la
recevabilité de l'article 3 bises de la
proposition de loi qui avait été
introduit par un amendement de sur le
rapporteur Philippe Brun lors de
l'examen par la commission des finances
commission des finances où je note pour
pointer le fait qu'il y a eu plusieurs
évolutions de jugement sur la question
de cet article que à ce moment-là
personne n'a évoqué aucune qui
recevabilité
la décision que j'ai rendu qui est
écrite et motivée si vous voulez bien
m'écouter chers collègues vous pourrez
agir c'est votre façon de de traiter la
parole madame berger vient donc la
décision que j'ai rendue qui est écrite
et motivé a été porté à la connaissance
des membres du bureau de la commission
c'était en effet une demande express de
la majorité du bureau qui s'est réunit
ce matin que l'article 3 bis ou à
contrôlé au regard des exigences de
l'article 40 de la Constitution le
raisonnement que j'ai suivi après avoir
pris en considération à la fois
l'ensemble des arguments portés à ma
connaissance tant par les membres du
bureau que par l'auteur de l'amendement
je note aux membres du bureau ce matin
que je les ai avertis que j'allais
prendre en considération des éléments
nouveaux apportés par l'auteur de
l'amendement m'a conduit à considérer
que cet article institut pas une charge
publique
il va de soi il va de soi il va de soi
que j'ai souhaité exercer en toute
impartialité mon office si vous écoutez
mes arguments vous aurez peut-être plus
de possibilités d'y répondre
il va de soi que j'ai souhaité exercer
en toute impartialité mon office et que
j'ai examiné attentivement l'ensemble
des textes applicables en ayant pour
objectif à partir d'un argument
juridique recevable de permettre du coup
de faire vivre le débat parlementaire
sur le fond ce dont je ne doute pas que
chacun ici considéra que c'est quelque
chose de nécessaire surtout sur cet
article donc dès l'importance j'ai
considéré d'abord que cet article 3
bises créé de façon claire et manifeste
de nouveaux tarifs réglementés de vente
d'électricité applicable à de nouvelles
catégories de consommateurs dès lors la
deuxième question à trancher était de
savoir si ces nouveaux tarifs pouvaient
créer une charge publique nouvelle pour
cela j'ai examiné très attentivement les
dispositions législatives applicables au
tarif réglementés de vente d'électricité
or les dispositions qui prévoient une
compensation par l'état des pertes de
recettes des fournisseurs d'électricité
lorsqu'ils lorsqu'ils appliquent des
réglementer prévu par l'article
l337-7 du code de l'énergie sont ainsi
rédigés qu'elles ne concerne que les
tarifs ayant fait l'objet en 2023 de
propositions motivées de la Commission
de régulation de l'énergie conduisant à
ce qu'ils excèdent de 15 % ce applicable
au 31 décembre 2022 les nouveaux tarifs
réglementés de vente d'électricité
électricité d'électricité pas institué
par l'article 3 bises de la profession
de loi numéro 808 non par définition pas
été applicables au 31 décembre 2022 il
n'entre donc pas dans le champ des
tarifs ouvrons droit à une compensation
par l'État en résumé en résumé en résumé
j'ai considéré que la rédaction de
l'article 180
de la loi de finances pour 2023 si elle
prévoit bien
si elle prévoit bien une compensation
par l'État en faveur des fournisseurs
d'électricité pour l'application des
tarifs régulés n'est pas applicable au
nouveau public éligible au tarif
régulier en application de l'article 3
bises de la propulsion loi le seul fait
d'étendre les tarifs régulés de suffit
pas à caractériser une charge publique
il faut que cette extension il faut que
cette extension il faut que cette
extension se combine avec une prise en
charge budgétaire dès lors que la prise
en charge budgétaire n'est pas
clairement et expressément prévu par le
texte elle ne se présume pas vous allez
sans doute vouloir me rétorquer que en
pratique vous allez sans doute pouvoir
vouloir me rétorquer que en pratique
c'est il lui réalise d'imaginer que
l'extension des tarifs régulés à de
nouveaux publics pourraient être imposés
à tous les fournisseurs d'électricité
sans qu'il soit compensés au moins pour
partie c'est peut-être un point de vue
acceptable en termes de raisonnement
économique mais le raisonnement que l'on
applique pour apprécier la recevabilité
financière est un raisonnement juridique
en maintenant une stricte analyse
juridique je n'ai pas contrevenu ainsi à
la pratique constante du contrôle de la
recevabilité financière ce qui permet
que cet après-midi nous dépassions de
l'Artis 3 bises merci
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît toujours le même article
d'accord s'il vous plaît
je réponds à la réponse
s'il vous plaît si s'il vous plaît
allez-y
[Musique]
plus ce sera calme plus vite ça ira donc
s'il vous plaît vous le laissez parler
merci allez-y
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances avec tout le respect que
j'ai pour vous il va falloir que nous
expliquer pendant une heure de
discussion générale nous avons entendu
l'ensemble des orateurs de la newspace
vous expliquer que ça allait faire
économiser de l'argent à toutes les
entreprises si on appliquait cette loi
et maintenant vous nous expliquez que ça
ne va rien coûter faudrait quand même
choisir donc évidemment
que l'application de cette point va
coûter de l'argent le rapporteur
lui-même a fait le lien entre le terme
et le bouclier tarifaire bien évidemment
que c'est ça qui est en question c'est
une violation de l'article 40 de la
Constitution et je voudrais m'adresser
ici au
groupe politique responsable nous
n'avons pas le droit de faire cela
monsieur le ministre allez-y
merci madame la Présidente je ne
souhaiterais évidemment en aucun cas
faire durer les débats mais je voudrais
quand même réitérer monsieur le
président
que notre estimation de cette mesure
c'est quand même 18 milliards d'euros
sur la base d'un calcul très simple
puisque je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
l'information sur les factures madame
rabot on les a et donc effectivement si
on plafonne à 280 euros le mégawatt les
contrats signés au second semestre 2022
nous couvrirons l'ensemble des contrats
j'en profite pour préciser cette
précision qui me semble opportune les 18
milliards d'euros il va bien falloir les
payer et d'après ce que je me souviens
de mes anciens souvenirs de président de
commission quand on crée de nouvelles
mesures qui dépensent 18 milliards
d'euros d'argent public on s'oppose
quand même la question de leur
financement ou à défaut on les déclare
et recevable
je vous remercie rappelle au règlement
les
i merci madame la présidente rappelle
règlement au titre du
54-5 l'intérêt du débat et 89-4
recevabilité financière je rejoins
évidemment ce qu'a dit le rapporteur
général je voudrais ajouter que
effectivement dans les débats ça a été
dit l'électricité n'est pas un bien
comme un autre mais notre Constitution
et notre bien commun en l'occurrence la
Constitution c'est la protection de
institutions l'article 40 est très bien
écrit et très clair les propositions
amendement formulées par les membres du
Parlement ne sont recevables lorsque
leur adoption aurait pour conséquence
soit une diminution des ressources
publiques soit la création ou
l'aggravation d'une charge publique il a
été expliqué à la fois par le rapporteur
général et par le ministre que l'article
3 bis engendre une dépense une charge à
hauteur de 18 milliards d'euros alors
Monsieur le monsieur le Président de la
Commission certes vous avez donné une
explication le groupe démocrate n'est
pas convaincu par votre explication vous
vous demandons de préciser comment
l'article 3 Suisse a pu passer les
filtres de la commission des finances je
vous remercie monsieur
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
d'abord sur le débat juridique sur la
solidité de l'article 40 ce débat ne
sera porteur général je sais pas où il
est passé et légitime il est légitime et
je dois vous avouer monsieur rapporteur
général que ayant les mêmes doutes que
vous
l'amendement qui a créé l'article 3 bis
je l'avais proposé sous deux rédactions
différentes une première rédaction qui
était gagée c'est à dire où il y avait
écrit c'est un peu artificiel mais que
le coup était pris en charge par les
entreprises et une seconde rédaction qui
effectivement ne comportait pas ce gage
il se trouve que en commission il se
trouve laissez-moi laissez-moi finir
madame la Présidente berger il se trouve
qu'en commission cette amendement a été
déclaré recevable et donc c'est la
version non gâché qui a été adopté alors
ensuite il faut regarder précisément à
la fois l'objectif de l'amendement et le
dispositif vous avez raison de dire
monsieur le rapporteur général que
l'objectif était bien détendre le
bouclier tarifaire et quand cela
l'objectif constitue une charge mais
lorsque nous regardent le dispositif
lance par le dispositif
tel qu'il est écrit et vous pouvez dire
que ma maman est d'ailleurs mal écrit
dispositif n'importe pas application de
l'article de la loi de finance initiale
pour 2023 et donc en vérité l'article 3
bis aujourd'hui tel qu'il est écrit
n'emporte pas extension du bouclier
tarifaire pour les commerçants et les
artisans il emporte en vérité
laissez-moi terminer il emporte en
vérité création d'un tarif réglementé et
vous devez savoir comment sont créés les
tarifs réglementés disons-le je on débat
technique on est on est sur un Rappel de
règlement un débat technique comment
écrire un tarif réglementé donc vous
savez que contrairement à l'article
l337-4 du code de l'énergie il y a
d'abord une proposition tarifaire qui
est faite par la creux par les biais
d'une délibération selon la méthode des
empilements de coût vous savez donc
c'est la méthode légale en l'absence
d'une refonte plus globale du chercher
de l'énergie et ensuite le gouvernement
peut décider ou non par un arrêté de
baisser le prix proposé par la creux
bien et c'est une fois que ce tarif est
proposé qu'ensuite gouvernement peut
décider ou non de le subventionner je me
permets de rappeler là cette fois-ci sur
le fond de la mandement qu'aujourd'hui
le tarif réglementé pour ceux qui
bénéficient du bouclier tarifaire les
entreprises qui en bénéficient est tels
que à moins de 36 kilos volts ampères
c'est le la mesure mise en place par le
gouvernement le tarif est fixé à
343,62 euros hors taxes du mégawatt très
bien et l'accord que vous avez signé
monsieur le ministre avec les
fournisseurs alternatifs et l'ensemble
des fournisseurs et de 280 euros du
mégawatt donc vous voyez bien que ce que
nous vous proposons ne va absolument pas
coûter 18 milliards si vous avez si vous
décidiez en vérité de le subventionner
donc ce chiffrage est absolument
fantaisiste il ne repose sur rien il
repose souvent pour simple et bonne
raison que le tarif n'a pas été encore
proposé par la creux et comme nous nous
fournissons pas de chiffrage du tarif
dans ce dispositif on est incapable de
savoir combien cela va coûter cela
dépendra de quel tarif et choisi par la
puissance publique et de quel prise en
charge ensuite de ce tarif par le
bouclier tarifaire voilà les réponses
que je voulais apporter sur un débat qui
doit demeurer technique et nous aurons
tout le loisir d'avoir un débat
politique sur l'article 3 bis pour merci
la parole est à Madame Le Pen pour un
rappel au règlement
pardon madame la Présidente mais un
rappel règlement pour dire que tout ce
que nous avons entendu là n'a rien à
voir avec des rappels au règlement je
veux dire si un débat politique à avoir
on l'aura au moment du 3 bis en
l'occurrence la recevabilité de
l'article de Travis a été tranché ce
matin en commission donc le débat
juridique ou le débat de fond aura lieu
au moment de la discussion du trabis et
s'il est comme je le souhaite d'ailleurs
voter libre à vous postérieurement de
saisir le Conseil constitutionnel si
vous avez encore des reproches je vous
remercie rappelle au règlement monsieur
Lefebvre
merci madame la Présidente au titre de
l'article 89 alinéa 4 de notre règlement
au panthéon de la mauvaise foi vous
aurez mes chers collègues une place
d'honneur une place d'honneur parce que
vous nous dites aujourd'hui à cet
amendement de constitue pas une charge
pour les finances publiques parce qu'il
ne coûte rien mais s'il ne coûte rien
c'est qu'il est inutile et c'est une
hypocrisie de plus dans votre défense
des petits commerçants et des artisans
une hypocrisie de plus parce que vous
avez rejeté toutes les mesures qui ont
permis de protéger le pouvoir d'achat de
nos commerçants de nos indépendants et
de nos artisans une hypocrisie de plus
mes chers collègues parce que vous
faites croire que vous protéger les
boulangers de ce pays alors que dans le
projet de loi des retraites vous
augmentez de 700 euros par mois du coup
d'embauche d'un salarié
l'article 40 de notre constitution
l'articarante de notre Constitution ça
veut dire quelque chose de Gilles Carrez
un Jérôme Cahuzac en passant par Pierre
maiseri son contrôle a été assuré de
façon impartial il y a aussi l'article
45 de notre Constitution l'article 3
bismes chers collègues n'aurait jamais
dû être déclaré recevable au titre de
l'article 45 de la Constitution
puisqu'il n'a rien à voir avec l'objet
de cette proposition de loi pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons il vous reste
mes chers collègues encore un petit peu
de temps pour faire abandonorable nous
avons déposé un amendement de
suppression à l'article 3 bis vous aurez
tout loisir de supprimer cet article
parce que déposer un amendement d'engagé
faire preuve de cette hypocrisie la plus
crasse c'est scandaleux je vous rappelle
quand même qu'au niveau des suspensions
de séance c'est limitées par deux par
groupes c'est pas c'est le règlement
[Applaudissements]
donc là
c'est
nous allons reprendre calmement sur
l'article 3 bis avec Madame châtelain en
première oratrice
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
je suis ravie qu'après des tentatives
finalement de ne pas mettre à la
discussion cet article parce que la
vérité c'est que vous ne voulez pas
assumer vos votes et vous ne voulez pas
affiner le refus de cet article sur les
tarifs réglementés parce que vous savez
qu'on en a besoin et je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui votre
boucle est tarifaire il ne fonctionne
pas il ne fonctionne pas parce que
notamment les plus modestes vont quand
même avoir une augmentation de leur
facture et que le plus riche pourront
continuer à surconsommer et que ça c'est
pris en charge par le bouclier tarifaire
il ne fonctionne pas parce que les
collectivités territoriales supportent
une augmentation des prix de l'énergie
qui vont que parfois elles ne peuvent
pas remplir avenir leur mission vous le
savez très bien moi dans ma
circonscription aucun mer n'est aidé il
porte seul l'augmentation des tarifs de
l'énergie et la question c'est le
fonctionnement des cantines c'est les
gymnases c'est aujourd'hui c'est le la
manière de vivre de nos concitoyens et
c'est la même chose c'est le petit
artisans c'est les commerçants qui
aujourd'hui sont qu'à la gorge par
l'augmentation des coûts de l'énergie
c'est ça la réalité vous n'assumez pas
vos votes vous vous cachez derrière
quelque chose de réglementaire alors
qu'en fait la vérité elle est politique
allons vote assumez vos votes devant les
Français remettez les tarifs réglementés
je vous remercie je rappelle aux
règlements monsieur marlex à me soulier
monsieur Marley
merci madame la Présidente il est
étonnant de constater à quel point
visiblement quel article s'il vous plaît
le gouvernement et la majorité sont en
panique sont en panique parce qu'on
propose d'évoquer la question du prix de
l'électricité que paye nos entreprises
la réalité c'est que depuis 9 mois vous
avez apporté aucune réponse à la
question dont souffre des centaines des
milliers de petits commerçants
d'artisans et de nombreuses PME monsieur
le ministre qui est pour qui vous
subventions hauteur de 20% ne sont pas
du tout à la hauteur donc l'Assemblée
nationale doit débattre de cette ce
sujet et vous devez enfin apporter des
réponses c'est l'occasion ou jamais de
vous cacher pas derrière la procédure je
vous remercie j'ai un autre appel au
règlement monsieur Houllier allez-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes vraiment un spécialiste
puisque ça fait pas plusieurs reprises
laissez-moi vous moi je vous ai pas
interpellé ça fait à plusieurs reprises
qu'en tant que président de la
commission des lois vous permettez
d'essayer j'ai gagné de déstabiliser le
rôle du sol président de la commission
qui est d'opposition c'est votre
spécialité alors je vais vous répondre à
chaque fois vous aviez tort vous aviez
tort juridiquement à chaque fois vous
aviez tort juridiquement et vous avez en
plus l'idée
de penser que vous avez l'omniscience
sur la question juridique vous avez
évoqué l'amendement sur les soignants
l'abondement sur les soignants le même a
été accepté par le Sénat et déclaré
constitutionnel j'ai accepté la décision
de la Présidence de l'Assemblée parce
que je ne pouvais pas faire autrement
mais j'estime que juridiquement j'avais
raison le deuxième amendement que vous
évoquez c'est l'amendement où j'avais
demandé au ministre de la Justice de
faire en sorte d'introduire l'idée qu'il
fallait un rapport pour justifier le
fait qui est un moratoire sur la
surpopulation en prison et j'avais
demandé ce rapport raison qu'il a il a
refusé la présence de l'Assemblée lui a
donné raison sauf que figurez-vous j'ai
interpellé le Conseil constitutionnel et
j'ai eu la grande surprise de découvrir
puisque cette notion de rapport était
absolument indispensable que dans le
49-3 le gouvernement avait introduit sur
cet abonnement cette question de rapport
preuve qu'il était pas tranquille par
rapport à ça donc vous avez tort alors
arrêtez arrêtez de donner arrêtez de
jouer dehors de leçon c'est
insupportable je vais vous dire une
autre chose j'ai examiné des dizaines de
milliers d'amendements depuis un moment
d'art j'ai fait en sorte et je l'ai
assumé d'essayer de trouver comme c'est
le cas quel que soit le positionnement
des amendements proposés j'ai toujours
dit que j'ai essayé de faire en sorte
que le débat prévaut et qu'à partir du
moment où je trouvais des possibilités
que l'article 40 ne soit pas appliqué je
le revendiquais j'ai descendu à peu près
de 20% à 11%
probabilité de l'article 40 et le
Conseil constitutionnel n'y a rien
trouvé à dire c'est ça la réponse par
rapport à ma crédibilité et non pas la
vôtre pour merci rappel au règlement
monsieur Bernal ici
allez-y merci Madame la présence sur la
base de l'article 89 alien et A4 sur le
l'application de l'article 40 dans notre
assemblée juste pour clôturer le débat
parce que l'intervention du président
Coquerel a terminé là-dessus
il me semble il me semble
qu'il y a en définitive un organe qui
est chargé de vérifier c'est ce qu'on
raconte est vrai ou faux ça s'appelle le
Conseil constitutionnel donc de vous
inquiétez pas si vous avez raison il y
aura une censure du Conseil
constitutionnel à la fin et pour le coup
vous n'avez pas de matière
constitutionnelle et de jurisprudence
sur la question de l'application de
l'article 40 puisque le Conseil
constitutionnel n'a que très peu voire
quasiment jamais censurer au titre de
l'article 40 de la Constitution parce
que et donc c'est une prétenture qui est
faite ici à l'Assemblée nationale une
auto-censure et le président concret a
raison de vouloir faire en sorte que le
débat parlementaire puisse être le plus
grand et le plus large possible si vous
n'êtes pas d'accord vous ferez une
saisie nos conseils concites fin de
l'histoire
menace s'il vous plaît dans un autre
appel au règlement allez-y mon cher
collègue
oui merci ma présidente au regard de 49
4 également et pour réponse à mon cher
Hugo
l'élément ne font que commencer donc ton
invention va pas la clôturer la
présidence ce que je voulais dire à cet
instant par rapport à l'appréciation
donc qui nous intéresse c'est qu'il ne
s'agirait pas de susciter de faux
espoirs chez nos concitoyens que cet
article s'il était voté à chacun s'en
fera les gorge chaud certainement pour
le vendre mais qu'en soi madame la
Présidente on trompe près les Françaises
et les Français regarde l'appréciation
du Conseil constitutionnel de l'article
40 et il ne s'agirait pas non plus que
nous crayons une jurisprudence
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
il y a Monsieur jumelles
merci madame la Présidente
allez-y tout à l'heure tout à l'heure
quel article 89 4 tout à l'heure le
président Marleix a dit que le la
majorité non non c'est pas fait
personnel vous allez voir je vais aller
dans votre sens
a dit que nous paniquions moi j'avoue
oui je panique un peu
[Applaudissements]
monsieur monsieur Boyard qui applaudit
j'avoue je panique un peu un petit peu
monsieur Balanant du rappel au règlement
là madame la Présidente je peux j'ai
deux minutes je vais faire
au règlement dur 2 minutes s'il est
fondé mais là en l'occurrence il n'est
pas fondé
[Applaudissements]
il se rappelle au règlement terminé
sinon on avance je peux te dire et
répondre et à ce voilà je vais le faire
mon rappel règlement donc
depuis ce matin depuis ce matin il y a
des contestations
nombreuses sur les procédures de notre
assemblée nous avons un règlement dans
ce règlement il y a annexé à notre
règlement la Constitution la
Constitution c'est le socle de notre
démocratie et au-delà de ce socle il y a
aussi des pratiques et les pratiques
c'est l'attitude des uns et des autres
et je suis particulièrement choqué à 7h
de voir sur les réseaux sociaux un
certain nombre de choses qui sont la
continuité de nos débats un député mais
au pylori les députés que nous sommes
parce que nous avons pas voté un article
et un autre député mais sous son pied la
tête d'un ministre est-ce que cela est
tolérable je ne le crois pas alors oui
madame la Présidente oui mes chers
collègues je panique sur l'état de notre
démocratie je vous remercie monsieur
Balanant monsieur
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente juste
préciser que en tant que rapporteur
général sur un texte financier j'ai le
droit de prendre la parole et je serai
le plus court possible dire simplement
dire simplement c'est que nous avons
hâte de discuter de ce texte sur la
nationalisation d'EDF et qu'il n'y ait
pas d'ambiguïté par rapport à ça aucune
ambiguïté pour ça évidemment pas
d'accord sur ce texte ce que nous disons
là simplement c'est qu'il y a un péché
originel dans ce texte qui s'appelle
l'article 3 bis et c'est de lui dont on
parle je voudrais m'adresser au
président
Coquerel il a refusé un certain nombre
d'amendement qui était
identique sur l'extension du trve au
titre de l'article 40 pourquoi n'a-t-il
fait pour cela et pourquoi ne l'a-t-il
pas fait pour celui qui aujourd'hui dans
le texte cette question me paraît
extrêmement importante et je voudrais
dire aussi que ma conception de la loi
ça n'est pas bon écoutez c'est pas grave
on respecte pas l'article 40 le Conseil
constitutionnel le dira après ça n'est
pas ma conception je crois qu'il faut
d'abord respecter la Constitution
bien sûr
très bien je vous remercie donc nous
continuons
non
monsieur on continue s'il vous plaît
alors non s'il vous plaît je donne la
parole à Monsieur le Ministre et après
nous continuons sur les orateurs
inscrits sur l'article 3 bis je vous
remercie madame la Présidente merci le
gouvernement demande une suspension de
séance de 10 minutes et si mes souvenirs
de députés sont bons je pense qu'elle
est de droite merci
à droite suspension de séance de 10
minutes
reprise de la séance donc dans le calme
la parole est à Monsieur sangsue du
groupe GDR
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur je
vais essayer de revenir au fond du débat
de l'article 3 bis lundi prochain je
vais recevoir à nouveau des commerçants
des artisans qui ne peuvent plus devant
la hausse vertigineuse de leur facteur
d'électricité
je peux parler merci
alors
madame la Présidente s'il vous plaît on
recommence pas dans les mêmes termes la
parole est à Monsieur censure on
l'écoute et après vous aurez la parole
je vous remercie j'ai cru comprendre que
c'était monsieur le rapporteur général
c'est très embêtant mais c'est comme ça
alors je ne vais pas faire la liste de
ces commerçants artisans qui voient leur
facturer mais même à 280 euros hors
taxes du mégawattheure c'est une
multiplication par 2 ou par 3 et toutes
les redesontades n'y changent rien ça ne
marche pas tout simplement alors la
seule solution vous savez d'habitude on
dit c'est la révolution mais là c'est
pas la révolution c'est sûrement
l'application d'un tarif réglementé pour
tous dans le cadre d'un service public
sous forme d'un épique d'un service
public de l'électricité intégrée rénovée
alors on peut se cacher derrière des
argusies pour échapper au débat
politique il ne faut pas échapper au
débat politique vous savez moi je ne
vais pas rappeler je ne vais pas
rappeler les 10 49-3 le 47 1 l'article
122 du règlement tordu je ne rappellerai
pas ça je veux juste rappeler mes chers
collègues aujourd'hui on peut avoir un
débat sur ce sujet majeur pour sauver
nos commerçants nos artisans nos petits
entreprises notre petite entreprise il
ne faut pas l'éluer et je j'ai surtout
envie de dire que lundi je serai fier
d'annoncer à mes commerçants artisans
qu'une solution est possible et qu'elle
a été votée par l'Assemblée aujourd'hui
je vous remercie je rappelle au
règlement madame berger
[Applaudissements]
oui merci madame la Présidente
assurez-vous ce sera le dernier appel au
règlement d'abord sur le fondement de
l'article 70-2 pour dire que des faits
graves ont eu lieu qu'à la fois la tête
du ministre Olivier du sort tu as été
symboliquement écrasé par un de nos
députés portant l'écharpe tricolore et
qu'il a publié sur les réseaux sociaux
je ne crois que ça n'est pas comme ça
qu'on doit traiter la démocratie ensuite
sur le fondement de l'article
89-4 sur la recevabilité financière qui
évidemment est mise à mal ici nous
refusons de participer à ce qui est un
déshonneur pour l'assemblée nous devons
respecter notre construction dans ces
conditions la majorité présidentielle
refuse de continuer à participer à sa
débats qui ne sont qu'une mascarade
qui se passe là
nous allons donc poursuivre les débats
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie nous allons continuer
monsieur sensuel est terminé monsieur
Lefebvre je constate qu'il n'est pas là
la parole est à Monsieur Loubet du
groupe rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre la situation est surréaliste
alors que nous cherchons une solution
pour sauver des dizaines de milliers
d'entreprises qui sont en détresse les
députés macronistes font non seulement
une obstruction politicienne indécente
mais en plus viennent de quitter
l'hémicycles je crois que cette
obstruction et cette absence démontre
une fois de plus au mieux qu'ils sont
déconnectés des réalités au pire une
indifférence face aux difficultés des
nombreuses entreprises qui font vivre
notre pays
à cause d'un plafond absurde de
puissance de compteur près de 80% des
boulangers ne peuvent pas bénéficier des
tarifs réglementés de vente de
l'électricité c'est tarif permettrait de
limiter considérablement la hausse de
leur cou énergétique une situation
injuste que subissent de nombreuses
artisans commerçants et industrie dans
notre pays c'est pourquoi le
rassemblement national soutient cet
article qui propose d'étendre les tarifs
réglementés à l'ensemble des TPE PME et
et qui le souhaitent si cette mesure est
nécessaire face à l'urgence à une
solutionne toutefois pas durablement ni
structurellement le problème de hausse
des prix de l'énergie dans notre pays
actuellement à cause du marché européen
de l'énergie nous payons un prix de
l'électricité qui est trois fois voir
parfois pardon dix fois plus élevé que
son coup de production en France face à
cette inflation aussi intenable qu'un
justifiée plutôt que dilapider plus de
100 milliards d'euros à travers un
bouclier tarifaire qui ne corrige même
pas la moitié des hausses des factures
énergétiques monsieur le ministre ayez
le courage de revoir les règles absurdes
du marché européen de l'énergie monsieur
le ministre vous savez que ce texte peut
être adopté c'est la raison du cirque
que vient de jouer l'ensemble de vos
députés ayez la dignité de sauver nos
entreprises plutôt que vous rabaissez à
cette obstruction qui est honteuse une
obstruction théâtrale qui condamne les
entreprises que vous prétendez pourtant
défendre je vous remercie
je vous remercie donc je vais mettre au
voile la proposition de loi
je vous prie de bien vouloir regagner
vos places
tout le monde est à sa place oui le
scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin et clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 210
s'exprimer de 106 majorité sans 4 pour
205 contre 1 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté
la parole est à Monsieur Coquerel
juste quelques mots avant de de la
passer à la personne qui est la plus
légitime à prendre la parole c'est à
dire Philippe Brun
j'allais dire que ça a été une séance
énergie qui est très franchement je ne
m'attendais pas je ne souhaitais pas
être au centre un moment donné de ses
débats je voulais du coup passer de
message bon je suis effectivement très
satisfait qu'on est voté sur le fond
cette loi parce qu'elle me semble est
une garantie contre le démembrement
d'EDF mais aussi notre souveraineté
parlementaire sur le devenir de cette
entreprise énergétique et je voudrais
dire que sur l'article 3 bis puisque
j'ai entendu pas mal de choses y compris
de certaines pressions qui sont montées
je vous dis à très calmement que je
conçois mon rôle de président de la
commission des finances comme d'essayer
à chaque fois que c'est possible et à
chaque fois que j'ai un argument
juridique pour tous les groupes je
précise pour tous les groupes de faire
en sorte que les débats puissent venir
jusque dans l'assemblée pour qu'il se
tranchent politiquement en l'occurrence
je suis particulièrement satisfait c'est
vrai que grâce à cet amendement 3 bis et
bien des peut-être que nos petits
commerçants et les TPI auront le droit
au tarif réglementé est-ce que je
souhaite maintenant c'est que le débat
continue au Sénat et peut-être
ajouterons à jour tranquille au Sénat le
fait que les collectivités territoriales
est aussi le droit à ce tarif réglementé
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
je vous remercier du fond du cœur
l'ensemble des députés de la nation qui
ont ici exprimé un signal très clair
c'est celui du refus de la
marchandisation de l'énergie de la
marchandisation de l'électricité cette
le signal que aujourd'hui 9 février 2022
nous avons annoncé le début du retour du
service public de l'énergie
service public de l'énergie que nous
n'aurions jamais dû quitter
je veux remercier
les syndicats d'EDF et notamment l'Inter
syndical qui nous a aidé sur ce texte
depuis le début
inter syndicale sans laquelle
aujourd'hui le projet Hercule aurait vu
jour Monsieur le Ministre et notre
nationale aurait été démantelé et c'est
grâce à l'opposition des agents et des
syndicats que nous avons réussi cette
victoire je veux aussi remercier les
associations d'usagers qui nous ont
saisi qui sont se mobilisés les
collectivités locales qui elles aussi
ont mis en échec le projet Hercule et
notamment les syndicats intercommunaux
d'électricité et de gaz remercier cette
union nationale qui s'est exprimée
aujourd'hui et se remerciement ne serait
pas complet si je mettais de parler de
l'administratrice Alexandra Poirson qui
m'accompagne depuis le début et nous
avons la chance à l'Assemblée nationale
de pouvoir compter sur une fonction
publique parlementaire d'élite c'est une
chance que nous avons parmi les
parlements européens je veux rendre
hommage aux administrateurs de
l'Assemblée nationale
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur le Ministre
merci madame la Présidente
juste quelques mots pour dire que
j'aurais aimé peut-être entendre les
arguments de madame la députée Battistel
qui aurait peut-être pu me convaincre
que cette proposition de loi était bonne
elle ne les a pas présentés et donc je
tiens à réaffirmer avec force au nom du
gouvernement que 1 cette proposition de
loi me semble
inutile
inefficace un rebours des intérêts de
l'entreprise à rebours de l'indépendance
de RTE qui est absolument je pense que
là je vous écoute depuis une bonne heure
là si je pouvais avoir les trois minutes
sans être interrompu
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît la
parole est à Monsieur le Ministre donc
je reste convaincu et je tiens à le
rappeler que cette proposition de loi
est inutile inefficace qu'elle va
rebours des intérêts de notre producteur
national deux réseaux et transports
d'électricité je tiens à réaffirmer que
de mon point de vue et du point de vue
du gouvernement et j'ai le droit de le
faire au titre du règlement l'article 3
bis et tiret sauvage au tir de l'article
40 et au tir de l'article 45 et enfin
madame la Présidente j'aimerais demander
une suppression de séance de 3 minutes
et là encore si je ne m'abuse elle est
dedans merci oui j'avais d'ailleurs une
suspension de sens déjà de la part du
président Vallot elle est donc de 5
minutes je vous remercie